hey everyone and welcome back to episode
number 23 of the beginner to master spe
run you might notice that I'm in a
different habitat different setting I'm
actually in the midst of traveling right
now and within the next 24 hours I will
be flying overseas to the United Arab
Emirates I do have my first chess event
of the year coming up in the town of fua
a town city I've never been there before
so I actually don't know how big of a
place it is but I'll be competing in a
two-day event first day will be a puzzle
solving competition and then the next
day will be a blitz competition I'll
leave more information below if you're
interested about learning more so I do
want to note that my streaming schedule
and my Youtube upload schedule will be a
little bit more sporadic for the coming
days so I do appreciate everyone's
patience but I do hope to make cont tent
while I'm traveling so stay tuned for
that and I hope you enjoy the speedrun
uh coming into today I was rated 1205
had a lot of like really really
instructive games especially in the
openings I think there's a lot of
lessons to take away and I hope you
enjoy the episode and first opponent
playing RTS cookie I'll play
E4 and we have a King's Pawn KN have
three I've had this position many many
times through the series uh from both
colors
actually um now Knight F6 is the start
of the two knights defense and there's a
few moves that white can play here uh
Knight G5 is kind of the start of the
fried liver if I want to go into that um
there's Pawn D3 which is the most solid
move Knight C3 would walk into the
center fork trick so I don't want to do
that um yeah what do I want to do let's
go for a fried liver Knight G5 we'll see
how well my opponent is prepared here uh
D5 is the best move and take on
D5 now the true five liver is after
Knight takes D5 there's a move Knight
takes
F7 uh but my opponent's going for a
pretty tricky line which I sometimes
like to play from the black side this
move Knight D4 and there's a really cool
trap here uh that white could walk into
if I play D6 there's a long variation
which ends I think around move 10 or 15
with white getting M um I'm not going to
go into that but I'll show it after the
game uh I have studied this position
before and I I do know the best move is
Pawn C3 trying to exploit the Knight on
D4 so this is a nice move to um yeah to
put the pressure on and black does kind
of have to know what to do here to not
be in trouble uh of course the Knight
can move um only safe square is Knight
F5 which I think is
playable uh but the best move as far as
I know is Pawn B5 so we'll see what my
opponent comes up with
here maybe taking is also
playable uh to counter attack the Knight
although taking I'd probably wind up up
material we do see Pawn B5 and now um
yeah it's a weird situation because if I
take the Knight I lose the bishop
and uh then it it just becomes a very
strange Pawn
structure uh but I'm going to play the
move Bishop to F1 and this is still part
of my opening
preparation um it looks ridiculous
having recently developed the bishop to
move it all the way back to its starting
Square uh but the point of this move is
I'm keeping the tack on the Knight I
didn't move to E2 because that would
allow Knight takes E2 and I didn't move
to D3 three because that would allow
Bishop F5 which is a nice resource so
from F1 I'm putting the bishop on a
square where it can't really be
exploited and I'm keeping the attack
against a B5 pawn and meanwhile the
Knight still attacked and if it moves
then I'm going to take the pawn with
check so yeah black still is in a small
predicament now most players especially
at this rating level won't know this
line with C3 followed by Bishop F1 so
I'm not surprised that my opponent is
taking time here to try and figure out
what to do um I'm pretty sure there is a
some famous game Bobby fiser had white
from this position I believe he was
playing in the siml or he was giving the
Simo and he had famously lost within 15
moves um it can still be tricky for
white if black knows what to do I'm
pretty sure the best move is Knight
takes
D5 there was a time uh a few years ago I
gave a lecture for the St Louis chess
club on this exact variation I'm pretty
sure I showed the Bobby Fisher game so
if if I can dig up the link to that
lecture I'll link it
below but um it's been a long time since
I actually looked at these lines in
depth and it's possible it's the first
time for my opponent uh running into
this exact
line there's been so many games in this
series where I've been the one taking
time early sometimes to explain things
sometimes because I'm confused early on
and trying to figure out the best path
forward but um yeah I feel like this
game is going to be a a very big opening
lesson and I'll definitely want to take
the time afterwards to
explain uh some of the ideas which I
can't
explain uh in in this position so we see
Bishop G4 which is a
Counterattack it's not a move I've seen
before so this is uh kind of my first
moment where I'm on my
own um my first impression is just to
play Pawn F3 and I don't think there's
any other move to even consider here
like Knight F3 is just a big concession
meanwhile the queen has no good squares
Bishop E2 would get the queen trapped so
let's go for Pawn
F3 this is usually not a move you want
to play Early in the game because it
weakens the
king but here it's very much Justified
saving my queen attacking the bishop the
Knight is still attacked B5 is still a
Target and yeah with two minor pieces
attacked in Black's position it does
look like I'm going to be winning
material
here
we see Queen takes D5 so opponent is
giving me the option which piece to
capture I think both moves are probably
fine I'm a bit more inclined to take the
Knight first because then like assuming
black will save the bishop then I can
take the
pawn um maybe that looks strange to
allow Queen takes Pawn to attack the
king and the Knight but then I'll have
Queen E2 which will likely Force the
queen trade
so yeah let's go ahead and
take I guess it is possible black can
take back which would counter attack the
Knight but I think in all these lines
I'm going to be up a piece in the end
and it's just a matter of making sure
that black doesn't have any compensation
really I just have to make sure my king
is going to be safe and the Center opens
up okay we see Queen digs D4
so this actually gives me some options I
could take on B5 with check or take the
bishop right
away if I take on B5 then the bishop can
save itself with Bishop
D7 so yeah let's just win more
[Music]
material not scared of Queen E4 although
I am scared of Queen F2 which is a
Checkmate threat but there's definitely
ways to deal with that
um and maybe the first thing I can do is
take on B5 with
check yeah let's go for
this black can't deliver Checkmate when
the king the black king is
attacked and I think very likely next
move I'll play something like Queen F3
or queen E2 or Rook
F1 all of these moves will prevent
checkmates of course depending where the
black king moves too like King d8
Knight takes F7 will be
possible so King E7 is
played and I really like this move Queen
F3 because not only does it defend
against Queen F2 but it attacks the rook
and it attacks
[Music]
F7 on top of that I'm up a knight and a
bishop I guess for Pawn so things are
going very well here this is why it pays
off to uh be be prepared in the
[Music]
opening especially to be prepared
against kind of an offbeat uh but tricky
variation so yeah I'm not sure what
black should do here like it's it's so
difficult to have the rook and pawn
attacked I mean maybe black can play
F6 give the rook and then like go for
counterplay here
here it's very close to force mate I'm
casting Queen takes and
then King D6 and then Queen E6 and then
King will
run I don't see Force mate
though but yeah let's start by taking
now I think what I'll do is after King
D6 I'll play Queen
E6 and then I'll just look
to wait a minute I was going to say I'll
look to take the Knight but the knight's
defended so let me um let me be a little
bit careful
here almost have a moment of uh like
actual oh no my queen yeah maybe I'll
just look to keep checking the king
queen
C6 of course black is threatening Queen
F2 like after King B4 black is
threatening Maiden 2 with Queen F2 King
D1 Knight
E3 would be
Checkmate because the Rook pins a Pawn
on the
defile but I have the initiative I'm the
one attacking Black's King it looks like
I can just play A3
here if the king moves to A5 Queen A6
will be
Checkmate and the only other legal move
is King
B3 after
which after which I I'm pretty sure I
see Maiden two with Bishop A4 Queen
takes
A4 and then Queen C3
checkmates just double checking here but
yeah this is going to be a nice finish
Bishop
A4 the queen supports the bishop Black's
only legal move is to
take and then Queen
C3 okay so that was a pretty
extraordinary opening like not every day
you can
Checkmate the Po's King on B3 when
you're white in the first uh within the
first 20
moves but I do want to go back and
explain the lines in this variation CU
there is a lot to address I mean
starting with Knight G5 like in this
position the main line and the line that
most grand Masters play is Knight A5 and
this is probably the most reputable but
also the most
theoretical uh the fried liver at least
the main line of fried liver is after
Knight takes D5 and this is known to not
be so great for black because of Knight
takes F7 King takes F7 Queen F3 I don't
think I've had this exact position in a
speedrun just yet but um I've definitely
shown it before at least once the idea
is that yeah the knight's attack the
king's attacked Knight can't block
because there's a pin the best move for
black is to move forward but then the
king's a big Target white can pile on
the pressure and uh yeah White's
definitely for Choice from this
position so uh let me explain Knight to
D4 because this is a really tricky line
that will basically trap a lot of
amateur players cuz it looks very
attractive for white to play D6 in this
position unleashing the bishop and
targeting F7 but this is actually the
beginning of just walking into uh really
nasty line cuz black can take on D6 with
the queen and if white takes on F7 with
a fork it looks good for white but black
has Queen C6 counterattacking the bishop
and the pawn and I'm pretty sure there's
been tens of thousands of games that
have gone Knight takes rook and then
Queen takes G2 not taking the bishop but
taking the pawn because now The Rook is
almost trapped and after Rook F1 there's
Queen E4 almost check mate if the queen
blocks The Queen Is Lost and if the
bishop blocks then Knight F3 is SM mate
so I've had this position online
probably at least a few times I haven't
played this line in a while though from
the black
side and it's a line that um objectively
is dubious for black because of the C3
move and unfortunately for my opponent I
knew this move uh they responded in the
best fash by playing
B5 and uh yeah the only move to keep the
advantage here for white is Bishop F1 I
should explain Bishop
D3 uh runs into Bishop F5 which is a
nice kind of Counterattack because if
takes takes black is is doing fine and
if takes then takes black is also doing
fine so Bishop F1 just ensures Knight's
still attacked and yeah the best move
here for black is actually not to move
the Knight but to take on D5
Counterattack in this
Knight and yeah there was some fer game
that went like takes and then takes and
then takes and then King
d8 and then
castle and I'm pretty
[Music]
sure uh fiser was white he played Queen
F3 his opponent took the pawn and then
fiser took on F7
I may have mixed up the move order but
yeah if you look it up in uh like online
like how fiser lost in less than 15
moves I'm sure the game will come up and
the winning move from black in this
position is actually pretty incredible
uh if you want to pause the video and
try and find it uh feel free to do so
there's only one winning move for black
and that is Knight to F6 with the idea
that black is preventing white from
delivering Ma on E8 or D7
at the same time G2 is attacked and not
only is G2 attacked but black is also
threatening Bishop D5 to trap the queen
so it's an incredible multi-purpose move
uh basically there's at least four or
five purposes with this move between
defending these squares threatening mate
and clearing the D5 Square for the
bishop so um yeah fer was was a victim
to this line um if white is prepared
here of of course white should not take
on F7 after D3 White's doing quite well
so it's a a useful line to be aware of
if you play this from the white side but
going back to the game I think after
Bishop G4 and F3 I was just in the
driver's seats and uh yeah things just
just kind of spiral downwards for black
in uh in the game so hopefully a bunch
of lessons to take away from that first
one uh let's move on let's do at least
one more and play a new 10-minute
game playing pickle
so two out of two opponents today named
after food we had cookie and pickle so
this time we have a London opening I
will play Knight F6 and against the
London I like to play kind of a reverse
Queen's gabit early C5 and Knight
C6 White's very quickly building the
triangle formation now against this
specific setup the move that I really
enjoy going for is Queen to B6 and this
takes advantage of the fact that the B
Pawn uh is not defended by the C1 Bishop
induces white to play
B3 um so yeah it's still it's still
solid for white but I'm definitely
getting some nice active play and here I
would like to play E6 and complete my
kingside development but I should
definitely first develop this bishop I'm
debating between Bishop f 5 or Bishop
G4 I think both moves are very playable
I'll play Bishop G4 little bit more
aggressive pinning the Knight to the
Queen White plays H3 let's maintain the
pin I'll be okay if G4 and Bishop
G6 and the plan going forward from here
is um yeah is just to be solid Pawn
E6 Bishop E7 castling Rook
C8 still a matter of getting the pieces
to happy
squares now I guess it is a question if
I want to throw in the capture like pawn
diges
pawn um CU it's very common that black
will play this move eventually but I
think in this position there's no reason
to do so right away so I'll start with
Bishop
E7 if white takes then I don't mind
taking taking back and then I'll have
two Center pawns against one Center
Pawn white plays Queen C2 okay so
forming the battery I mean I can still
castle and the Knight will help defend
H7 but with this move Queen
C2 I think it makes Rook C8 a bit more
attractive yeah I'll start with this
move CU very often The Rook likes to be
on files that are likely to open and I
mean the SE files are most likely file
to open because of the pawn tension but
Rooks also like to be aligned with
opponent's queen or King in this case
yeah aligning with the queen and there
might be ideas of taking and then Knight
B4 with some pin and
Fork so Bishop G5 doesn't scare me too
much I'm going to start by taking
[Music]
here and if this Pawn
recaptures then Knight B4 could be a a
real
possibility it would be interesting if
the C Pawn recaptures cuz that Knight B4
would be a blunder due to Queen takes C8
nothing's defending the
Rook so then I might look to
Castle although I do have to be careful
with
castling of let's say like Pawn takes
pawn and I Castle then there's takes and
I lose
H7 white taking on D4 with the
Knight okay
so yeah there's some choices here I mean
Knight B4 it's a fancy move attacking
the queen and the bishop and unleashing
the
pin I think after Knight B4 white would
have to play Queen
B1 ah then KN can take on
C3 so that actually looks really really
nice
there's other options here too like I
could play E5 and expand Center although
E5 might allow Knight F5 and then things
got a bit
murky I really like the look of Knight
B4 because the queen is basically tied
down to the bishop and the pawn like
it's only defender of both D3 and
C3 and it's going to have
to probably just move back to B1 and and
surrender
C3 now it is possible white might get
some counterplay like assuming Queen B1
Rook takes
C3 white will have the move Bishop B5
check and then I might I might consider
just moving the king to
f8 but yeah let's go ahead and take the
pawn and I guess this is a the downside
of white having played B3 earlier like
like B3 just weakened the position a
little
bit and uh yeah the queen side for for
white is crumbling um now in this
position it might seem automatic just to
recapture on F6 I I was pretty close to
just like immediately playing Bishop
takes F6 uh but there's a stronger move
here because I can take on D3 with
check and yeah this wins material I mean
if Queen takes I'll take back with Rook
otherwise King F1 and then I'll take
back with the
bishop and black will be up uh a minor
piece and a
pawn so this is a nice example of how
to basically crack the London from early
on induced some some weakness on the
queen side and um yeah white is is
really just crumbling here now the
rook's attacked if I move the Rook I
lose a knight but I can take the
Knight which will simp
simplify and
now I mean there's there's a bunch of
options here I could Castle just leave
the Knight and rook in White's
territory I like the looks of Queen A6
simply reinforcing the Knight and
aligning with the white
king and if the king wants to get off
this
diagonal then it'll have to move here
here King D1 walks into the
fork King F3 really walks out into the
open and maybe it's the best move
[Music]
though oh King D1 also walks into Rook
C1 so white is uh is leaving the King
on
E2 now I'm pretty sure there's check
madeen two here I'm pretty sure there's
actually a couple moves to Maiden two uh
there's Knight F4 which is double check
and then whatever white does there's
Queen E2
Checkmate but even more stylish is
Knight C1 I think I'll play this
move um doesn't really make a
difference because the Rook is unleashed
the king can't move
up the king's in double check and yeah
Queen E2 is
Checkmate so a very strange
configuration of pieces the Rook defends
the Knight defends the Queen checkmates
the king uh not a mating pattern that
you see every day but a very nice way to
punish the London
opening and um yeah my opponent made
just some some subtle mistake early on
maybe playing B3 combined with Queen C2
allowed me to put on the pressure and
then um I think here white already had
to be aware of the danger uh like maybe
a move like A3 just to prevent Knight B4
engine saying this move is best just to
take and um yeah avoid the uh avoid
basically what happened in the game but
after Bishop
G5 yeah do Knight B4 move is very
Troublesome for
white and here yeah white should
probably play Bishop B5 check to save
the bishop get some initiative I was
probably going to play King f8 and um
yeah lose casting rights but still have
a very nice uh grip on the queen side
move like A6 is coming so uh definitely
a Fu good game hopefully some lessons
for viewers to take away from that game
uh let's move on let's do one
more rated
1220 and this time I have an opponent
that's not named after food we have E
Miller and E Miller is playing the
Polish opening which uh is not an
opening I've encountered in the speedrun
um this is also known as a ring
Aang which um yeah it's it's definitely
a non-traditional
opening uh now against the Polish or the
ring Aang what I like to recommend is
just taking the pawn if if white allows
it and even though I'm allowing the
trade of wing Pawn for Center Pawn okay
white doesn't even take the center Pawn
so um I'm just happy to win a pawn here
I was going to say if white did take
this Center Pawn I I would develop and
get an initiative on a bishop I can
definitely um elaborate after this game
is
over but um yeah white I guess is
playing some gabit here uh down upon but
trying to attack the
center so I think the strategy is just
to be solid like let's
defend and prepare to develop the final
minor
pieces p PA C4 okay it's um grabbing
some
space I'll keep
developing I'm not really too concerned
of A3 i' just drop the bishop back white
doesn't have a B Pawn to expand with to
uh keep attacking my
bishop and the bishop actually serves a
nice role in pinning this Pawn like
white can't easily expand with
D4 maybe white has to look to Castle
first or look to play this move first
so yeah let's just complete development
with
castling and then likely developing the
bishop to one of these squares
next I'm not actually sure which move is
best and there's definitely an argument
for all of these these Bishop moves
Bishop E6 is like the most
centralized Bishop F5 it does kind of
Pierce through the position position
Bishop G4 might induce some
trades I'm considering holding off on
developing the bishop
two like one move that comes to mind is
Pawn
E4 simply attacking the
Knight and sometimes a move like this is
a bit overextending but in this
case if the Knight moves here then I can
easily defend the pawn and look to play
H6
Knight moves here i' I'd be really happy
to take and double White's
pawns so yeah I'm going to hold off on
developing my bishop and just grab space
in the
center sometimes if you're not sure
whether to push the pawn you just want
to ask yourself if you have enough ways
to defend the pawn if it gets attacked
later I have a lot of ways to reinforce
it but yeah like I was saying I'll just
take on
D4 doubling White's Pawns
and now I guess it's still a
question like do I want to develop
immediately I probably do Bishop F5 nice
move to support the
pawn and one plan going
forward this bishop it's a bit out of
play I don't really want to take on
C3 and give white the bishop hair uh so
there's a plan here to play
C6 eventually D5 and Bishop C7 and have
the bishop on a really nice diagonal
aimed at White's King side so yeah I'll
start with
C6 and if I get in this move D5 I'll
have the really nice Pawn structure and
then I'll I'll be pretty well set up to
try and organize an attack against
White's King
side have basically all the minor pieces
aimed over
there and there is a general rule if
you're black and you have a a Pawn on e4
that's well defended and the opponent's
castled then you want to look to attack
the opponent's castled king so white
is attacking the
pawn I don't think white is actually
threatening to take the pawn though
because I I'll have Rook
B8 to then win the
bishop so maybe I can set up some trap
here like Bishop
C7 to start
yeah let's play Bishop
C7 very sneaky move of of course going
for my play on of D5 unleashing the
bishop but I'm also basically saying oh
no my
Pawn someone call an
ambulance but if white takes the pawn
that ambulance will not be for
me yeah Rook B8 white could then win one
of these pawns but then I'll win the
bishop
maybe white could consider playing D5
okay Rook B1 so white was seeing through
my trickery defending the bishop and
maybe preparing to take on
B7 um now with Rook B1 it is aligned
with my Bishop on
F5 so this move is really
tempting Pawn
E3 I don't actually know if it does that
much like Pawn E3 Rook
D1 we could
trade feel like I'm only helping light
with that
sequence I'm considering this
move to unleash and then maybe
eventually
Queen
D6 I'm also considering Rook B8 just to
safely reinforce the pawn so definitely
a few options to consider
here
I really don't think that E3 does that
much like Rook
D1 if I take on F2 Rook takes and file
opens in White's
favor so I think it's really a matter
between D5 and Rook
B8 and I'm just going to play Rook B8
because I didn't really want to
calculate the lines where I I sacrificed
a Pawn on B7 it's just a solid safe move
and looking to play D5 next move and
then hopefully shift the focus to the
king
side I'm also just preserving this E3
move for maybe later when it can be more
venomous to hit the Rook like maybe if
this Rook moves then E3 will actually
have the threat of taking on
F2 now white putting the bishop in the
corner I mean this does create the
battery but White's not really
threatening to take on
B7
so I'll play Pawn
D5 I should note here the Pawn's
defended three times so it's okay that
there's three
attackers take back and pawn is still
defended oh except yeah maybe white
miscounted because now I can take the
Knight and yeah generally when there's a
same number of Defenders as there are
attackers then um yeah then it's
officially defended I think my opponent
is realizing that now the queen should
uh should not continue to capture on
D5 white does have the battery but yeah
now it's time to save the
Knight or is it cuz there's move like
Queen
H4 threatening Checkmate or queen D6
threatening
Checkmate there's also a knight F4 just
migrating to the king
side yeah let's go for Knight
F4 the basic moves to threaten Checkmate
would probably walk into
G3 and I want to make it so that um yeah
I'm I'm just attacking with all the
pieces and this Knight on F4 is a a
great attacking piece now I do have to
watch out for this Queen Bishop battery
like it can be very easy to miss the
bishop in the corner or just forget
about the bishop in the corner and and
if white plays D5 next then it would be
a mate
threat but White's not threatening that
right
away um I'm drawn to this move Knight E2
of course The Bishop's covering E2
so uh I would have to remove the
bishop I think I'll just go for Queen G5
not only attacking but preemptively
defending
G7 think white is likely to play Pawn G3
here uh Queen G3 would walk into Knight
E2 the discovered Fork uh basically
double attacking the queen and checking
the
king so G3 we do
see and still not super easy to
crack Knight E2 is still off limits
Knight H3 is
possible
I think I will play Knight H3 attacking
the king I'll force the king to G2 or
[Music]
H1 and
then yeah this move Bishop G4 actually
looks really really
nice setting up Bishop to
F3 I just have a lot of attackers on the
king side with the bishop the Knight the
queen this Bishop's not playing a big
role but maybe will be useful in the
future and the threat in this position
is Bishop F3 that if King takes Knight
it will be
checkmates only other option would be to
lose the queen for white I'm also
realizing I might be setting up Knight
F4 after G takes F4 there's a double
check which would result in
Checkmate so it's not easy for white to
defend there yeah Rook E1 and now I have
the choice between Knight F4 or Bishop
F3 Let's Play Bishop F3 think is the
most
straightforward and white has two legal
moves one of which loses a queen the
other one yeah gets miden so pretty nice
game um yeah it was first time taking
down the Polish
opening uh I should explain kind of the
opening strategy cuz cuz a lot of
players just don't know any sort of
opening Theory or opening preparation
against B4 on move one and I'll admit
that the only only true line I know
against this is to play this and then
after Bishop B2 black is supposed to
take the pawn now most players would
take on
E5 and the reason why black is okay
trading off a center Pawn for a wing
Pawn early in the game I should note
that usually Center pawns are just more
valuable than Wing pawns early in the
game but in this case black gets an
early leading development Knight F6
already preparing to Castle and then
going forward black can play Knight C6
gaining time on the bishop and the fact
that white has two Center pawns it's
nice in some respect but it's even nicer
for black to get the early lead in
development to have the halfen E file
for The Rook yeah Rook E8 could also
attack the Bishop on E5 and black will
eventually play D5 and develop and um
yeah the engine already slightly prefers
black in this position um of course what
happened in the game my opponent just
gave the pawn without recapturing I was
up material basically the full game and
uh yeah this E4 move was nice to gain
space um yeah there some some
interesting moments on the Queens side
and I mean my opponent just gave gave
the piece maybe Mis Counting the number
of attackers and Defenders on D5 so
pretty clean game um again hopefully
some lessons to take away I think we'll
end it there for episode 23 if you have
questions leave them below uh I do
appreciate everyone who likes and
subscribes it does help the channel grow
and uh stay tuned for more I'll see you
guys soon